[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos la
guerra en ucrania se está librando desde
muchos frentes desde odessa en el mar
negro hasta a irving en el norte desde
mykolaiv hasta la capital de kiev en
este documental podrán ver el rastro de
la violencia y la devastación de ciudad
en ciudad también a muchos combatientes
que se unieron a la batalla a los
civiles que se esconden bajo tierra y a
las mujeres que dan a luz mientras caen
los proyectiles gwendolyn de bono la
periodista de france 24 autora de este
reporteros fue testigo del horror de la
guerra en la morgue de nikko life donde
los cadáveres se apilan hora tras hora
además siguió a los trabajadores
voluntarios de las ambulancias que
intentan sin descanso salvar a los
atrapados en el fuego cruzado aquí la
historia
[Música]
o de esa 9 y 30 de la noche el tren
nocturno con destino a kiev la capital
está en la estación
uno de los pasajeros stalin de 20 años
para él no es sólo un viaje a otra
ciudad sino también a otra vida
voy al frente a defender a mi país
ahora es como si ucrania fuera un solo
cuerpo todas las ciudades se unieron
como si fueran una sola
todos trabajan de la mano
de alguna manera esta es una situación
maravillosa creo que podemos ganar
sería muy difícil y tendremos que pagar
el precio pero definitivamente ganaremos
[Música]
en la morgue de mico life un soldado que
cayó abatido por un ataque ruso
expuesto en su ataúd por sus compañeros
y a mí
o
no
su madre acaba de reconocer su cuerpo
bueno
no nunca en muchos cultivos tanto
mira yo me borro a pie
sueño que ya no te callas mamá
un padre observa en silencio él también
está esperando poder reclamar el cuerpo
de su hijo
e
y
[Música]
me siento tan mal por estas familias
no logro expresar lo bien
fue hecho en todos los ambientes
a las ocho de la mañana empezamos a
ocuparnos de los cuerpos
y no paramos
los recibimos devolvemos a algunos a las
familias así todo el día
los cuerpos llegan sin cesar porque la
gente muere de salud es usted
los miembros de la unidad de orix under
de 22 años cierran su ataúd
los restos de los soldados ucranianos
siguen llegando pero en la morgue
civiles y combatientes enemigos yacen
uno al lado del otro
bruschi de vos esos son rusos aquí
también
el cuerpo de un ruso haya
1234 cuerpos también son rusos
a juzgar por sus heridas les dispararon
por la espalda mientras intentaban
escapar de nuestros militares
abandonaron su equipo sus armas
corrieron a través de los campos
le dispararon y luego no los trajeron
en mykolaiv la muerte se anuncia por el
sonido de los proyectiles a menudo
imprecisos y por el de las sirenas
cuando suenan la vida cotidiana se
vuelve subterránea en la sala de
maternidad las contracciones tensan los
rostros de las pacientes forzadas a ir
al sótano también es ahí entre las
tuberías y las salas técnicas donde hay
que disfrutar de los primeros momentos
de vida ellos son padres de la pequeña
de él de pocas horas de nacida
no es como si no hubiera esperanza ahora
somos felices y tenemos que seguir
viviendo sobreviviendo tenemos que
acostumbrarnos a esta nueva realidad a
la guerra de hecho cuánto tiempo lleva
ocho años desde que comenzó en 2014 ya
hemos pasado por situaciones difíciles
así que esperamos que la ciudad esté a
salvo pronto lo único que podemos hacer
es cruzar los dedos
una parte del sótano también se utiliza
como refugio para los habitantes de la
zona
el equipo médico ocupa el final del
pasillo y se adapta a la situación
si hay urgencias durante los partos las
subimos al primer piso
porque hay hasta el único quirófano
claro que es muy peligroso
en primer lugar porque hay grandes luces
en el quirófano lo que lo convierte en
un objetivo para los bombardeos
porque se pueden ver las luces a través
de las ventanas que son muy grandes
segundo tratamos de operar lo más rápido
posible
porque cuanto más tiempo permanecemos en
el quirófano más peligroso es
[Música]
esta mujer acaba de dar a luz a un niño
por cesárea
[Música]
en el sótano la alerta ha terminado las
mujeres vuelven a subir
en el fondo del refugio lina un
habitante de la zona termina su noche su
vecino comienza su día
[Música]
el tren nocturno procedente de odessa
llega a la estación de kiev but in
tendrá que esperar dos días antes de ir
al frente
y
[Música]
en la estación se encuentra con karen un
voluntario que lo acoge por el momento
karen acompaña a una madre y su hija que
abandona la capital viven en un barrio
de kiev que es bombardeado regularmente
[Música]
y
no
no no
[Música]
y espero que la mayoría de los rusos lo
entiendan
porque por ahora lo que tienen metido en
el cerebro es que están liberando a
ucrania de algo
cuando solo están capturando un país es
incomprensible de que nos están
liberando de nada sólo quieren
subyugarnos
[Música]
por su mano
y el pin el frente más cercano a kiev
la capital se encuentra más allá del
bosque
[Música]
sergio y taras se conocen este camino de
memoria estos dos conductores de
ambulancia voluntarios no recorren
varias veces al día para rescatar a los
habitantes atrapados
taras es ucraniano trabaja como médico
en la isla francesa de córcega y se fue
cuando empezó la guerra
ese día fueron a buscar a varias
familias atrapadas en el pino tres mil
habitantes siguen en la ciudad y ningún
barrio estaba a salvo de los combates
vamos a ver
amoroso
los habitantes son llevados a kiev a
salvo el segundo viaje para el primer
problema para ser hits y taras
no podemos acercarnos porque hay fuego
cruzado en el bosque
[Música]
están disparando no podemos acercarnos
hay combates en los alrededores las
fuerzas ucranianas quieren hacer
retroceder las posiciones de la
artillería rusa hay que ponerse a
cubierto y esperar
15-20 minutos
cuando acaban normalmente se tranquiliza
y podemos avanzar para buscar los
civiles
[Música]
o no
es para nosotros hay personas allá vamos
hay personas allá vamos
sergei acelera tienen permiso para
volver a salir
cuando llega a ir tina se subir a los
niños la pálida de sus rostros es
impactante han pasado las últimas
semanas en un sótano
la familia es evacuada tercera llamada
los habitantes esperan la ambulancia las
tropas rusas envían entonces una ráfaga
de mortero al punto de evacuación
lo que baile
el primer proyectil desequilibra a taras
los civiles están al frente quieren
hacerlo subir segundo proyectil luego un
tercero
cuatro cuchillas
por qué
los habitantes esperan a cubierto
los conductores de la ambulancia también
cuarto proyectil cae en la casa frente a
la ambulancia
taras les grita a los habitantes que
corran a la ambulancia
no ha prestado por todas decimos
[Música]
para el hit regresan a pesar de su
aprensión 20 minutos más tarde de vuelta
a la retaguardia cuentan los disparos
que tiene la ambulancia con la calma
también llegan las historias y los
rostros de quienes sufrieron toda la
fuerza de la guerra
los rostros de estos civiles son cada
persona es un destino es una
personalidad es una vida que ha pasado
una vida que ha comenzado una vida que
está llegando a su fin una vida que se
está desarrollando y todo eso es lo que
se destruye y se destruye
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de france 24
recuerde que para visualizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]